foreign
who we have both spoken with on her on
her podcast she goes by Posey Parker and
she is doing a let women speak tour and
she's been in the U.S uh she's been
she's she's British and she's now been
in Australia New Zealand this week
and uh in both cases there's been chaos
uh in the latter this week There's there
was violence against her and we'll show
a little tiny bit of of a video that
doesn't um that shouldn't
trigger anyone but first I want to share
a bit from a piece published in The
Spectator by the wonderful um I
apologize Petra I realize that I don't
actually know how to pronounce her last
name Petra buskins I'm going to say uh
and I'm going to just read a couple of
sections from this this piece that Petra
wrote while
um Kelly J was still in Australia before
she went to New Zealand this week so
this is called you can show my screen
here guilt by association
uh she says she writes Petra writes when
Victorian Premiere Daniel Andrews and
Progressive Party leaders such as the
greens Adam bant Define these women or
their protests that is to say the the
women of the let women speak to her
as associating with neo-nazis we have a
gross misrepresentation at play and one
that anyone participating in the charade
should be ashamed of this whole message
of orchestrated misrepresentation that
amounts to propaganda
it is obliterating the legitimate
concerns of women regarding the safety
and privacy of women and girls in Rape
Crisis centers women's shelters women's
prisons women's change rooms and toilets
it is sabotaging the discussion around
how women can possibly compete against
natal males in sport and have their
gross inequality of quotas prizes or
shortlist for women being filled by
trans identifying males it is also about
the loss of meaningful language for
motherhood including the removal and
replacement of words such as pregnant
woman mother and breastfeeding with
Abominations such as vulva owner
birthing people and chest feeder these
are important conversations nothing more
but also nothing less it is not and
never has been about the violation of
trans people's legal civil or social
rights it is about the recognition of
women's rights
just a couple more sections from this
wonderful article that the category of
woman is now being jettisoned or revised
beyond all recognition at the precise
historical hour that women in the west
have gained a political and cultural
voice is disturbing
moreover in redefining women's rights
almost entirely in terms of queer
identity politics crucial issues such as
women's poverty and homelessness sexual
and domestic violence and mothering and
Care work fade from view these issues
barely raise a mention as sex-class
transmogrifies into gender ID
assuming this debate is like other
debates between say liberals and
conservatives or between opposing
philosophical paradigms like positivism
and hermeneutics is sadly mistaken this
debate like so many in the contemporary
culture wars is on an entirely new
epistemological terrain what does at
stake here is nothing short of reality
itself
that's right so Petra is exactly right
here
and um you know I'm reminded of having
argued with people you know why are you
so upset about this and um you know it's
yeah sometimes I have said I feel like
I'm defending science itself and
sometimes it's reality itself and I am I
am just
startled and shocked at the level of
Disconnect with reality that many on the
so-called left have on this issue it is
it is utterly stunning let me just
introduce this and then I'm going to
have you share that uh 30 or 40 second
clip okay Zach
so
um
Kelly J was at this event in Auckland
um this is yesterday actually or maybe
it's two days ago because the time zone
is hard for me here on the west coast of
the United States to quite figure out
um
as were many other women there her
security might might have saved her life
she has that sense I don't know
um
this is this is her live streaming from
her phone as she was doing from before
she got out of the car and the event
doesn't end up happening because they're
concerned for her and she is now being
escorted by security back to her car you
want to show now Zach
[Applause]
[Music]
now at the end there I think that's her
security that's holding on to her not
not someone from the crowd but just to
repeat You Hear Voices all male
screaming at her get out of here go home
[__] you
all mail and you know how I can tell
because I'm a human being and we're a
sexually dimorphic species all male
voices yelling at her
as she's being escorted by security to
escape the mob because she cannot do the
event that she arrived to do
here's an eyewitness account from a
woman who happens to be 11 weeks
pregnant who showed up at the event I'm
just going to read it I will link to her
um sub stack
the protesters on the Rotunda were
overwhelmingly men not men in dresses as
you might expect at such an event
although there were some just ordinary
looking men they shoved women they
screamed in our face as they leered at
us and they tried to forcibly topple
over a section of Steel gate onto the
women Sheltering from them on the other
side of it
and the assailants continue to try to
make it look like they've won
so
um
Kelly J writes and you can show my
screen here if you want this is just a
little post on Twitter
she writes a long campaign to
assassinate my character started by a
group of jealous spiteful women in the
UK that I had Ambitions besides stopping
the mutilation of children and the
Eurasia of women's rights a load of Lies
slurped up by ravenous porn six porn
sick men and their trans maidens but
consistently legitimized by women on my
side the lies were finally spewed by
politicians in power in Australia and
New Zealand boosted by a corrupt media
populated by vile dishonest unskilled
cult members the end result was that I
spent most of my day with the protection
of police who genuinely believed I was
lucky to be alive
the advice was that I should go home I
was never the things that I had been
accused of I don't even believe they
believe it they just say it because they
cannot accept a woman walking her own
path and wants other women to find their
feet and walk theirs it may seem like we
lost a battle today but I promise we
will win this [__] War the powerful
are seeking to silence us we must
continue to speak they are afraid of us
so much love to the women of New Zealand
we see you the world is talking about
you to the steward security and police
who made sure my kids get to see me
again thank you thanks to all of you at
home who offered messages of support
and this was in response now you can
keep up my screen for a second you have
some response to someone
um some nasty person saying hey you
showed up at the airport looking pretty
fine
and someone else says have a bloody mary
to relax kjkk calling her and Nazi again
and she says am I supposed to feel
humiliated for being assaulted to
statistic you really have no idea about
me
and that strikes me you can give me my
screen back now Zach um as
a really powerful message
I'm supposed to feel humiliated for
being assaulted
that's that's standard
misogyny it is standard male aggression
against women right there
trying to humiliate her trying to make
her feel ashamed
for an attack on her
and she is standing up for women all
over the world who are getting
really tired of this
and
we will win
we have to win this is basic reality men
aren't women men can't become women and
the fact that in that little bit of
video that we played for you you hear
entirely male voices yelling at her and
telling her to go home
that tells you something right there
um
I've done a lot of thinking you've been
way ahead on this and your impatience
with all
all of the arguments that are deployed
in this space has I think been right on
Target and this as you know been the
part of me that has been concerned that
the tiny number of actually trans folks
uh are going to get brutalized in the
absolutely Justified reaction to trans
activism which is a very different
phenomenon
and
there is something
utterly misogynistic about this right
the the trans activism phenomenon where
um men declare themselves women and
insist on all of the Privileges and
advantages and rights of being born
female
is really the
um you know
patriarchy doesn't exist but misogyny
does and this is it
now
it does worry me you and I uh
had a number of trans students and I
worry about them
in an environment in which
this thing has taken over you know it is
basically utilized uh
the fact of transness whatever it is
whether it is an ancient phenomenon
whether it is a a the result of some
kind of modern dysfunction doesn't
really matter hormones in the water
um could be a lot of things maybe both
right but nonetheless there are a tiny
number of people who didn't ask for this
and don't deserve to get chewed up in it
and then there is this gigantic
phenomenon that is deranging us and
going after women and it is misogynistic
and what I realized is
I think the impatience is right
and I think the important thing to say
to people who are trans are not pushing
this agenda are not going after women's
rights they're just trying to exist
is that it is time that they have to
reject it doesn't matter that this
movement is claiming the mantle of
transness and claiming to advance the
rights of trans people right the point
is it's a misogynistic movement of men
pretending to be women that's not the
same thing as actual trans folks these
people aren't going to stick with this
they're just using it as a weapon
and I think you know I I have uh
championed Buck Angel and Blair white
because they have been courageous both
of them trans and both of them have been
courageous in opposing this garbage and
are really what I'm hoping to see is
that the tiny number of folks who are
trans because of where they find
themselves didn't join it in order to
get rights they're not entitled to that
those people will stand up and reject
this and stand you know alongside women
defending their position in the world
okay I want to go farther though
um and
say
uh men need to stand up because this is
men attacking women yes this is men
attacking women while claiming to be
women and a very few of them might be
confused
um and a lot of middle-class women are
seem to be confused about what women are
and I don't know what to say to them
honestly but I think fewer men are
actually confused about this but they
have been cowed into silence because it
seems like disagreeing is I don't even
know what disagreeing with women not
nice bad for civil rights
so I don't think I've ever before said
actually men we need you to stand up for
women here but like we we need that now
because there are a lot of women who are
being very vocal and
and I think the tide can turn I mean
what happened at the um the
what from the um the world Athletics
Council this week is is wonderful and
important but it's about Sport and I
care about sport but it's not as
important as uh as what is happening to
children and in Rape Crisis centers and
in prisons and to you know to Kelly J
Keen at an event in Auckland right it's
just not as important that the idea that
all you have to do is declare yourself a
woman and suddenly you get a pass and
you can brutalize women that's not okay
and uh although it would be a beautiful
world in which women didn't need the
help of men to help us stand up against
a Scourge when it's men who are coming
at us we actually need other men to
stand up so like that needs to happen
I think I know uh you know there are
obviously a large number of people who
um
are on the wrong side of this issue
despite the fact that they obviously
have the mental capacity to see what's
taking place and to do the right thing
what's got people
um
confused yeah and again going back to
the problem with the the major crisis
that we are facing in Civilization is
one of
um confusion across many many domains
including including this one but what's
got people
uh confused here
is the false analogy with past uh
instances of a civil rights fight this
is something yes disguised you know well
you know you wouldn't want to have been
on the wrong side of the fight for gay
rights of course no reasonable person
would right and so the point is oh this
is that fight you just don't see it yet
you're one of those people that history
will look back at and say how could they
possibly have misunderstood and the
answer is no that's not what this is
this is well both sides actually in this
case and maybe this often happens but
both sides are claiming no you guys are
really on the wrong side of history and
uh in this case
I actually have certainty and I try not
to have certainty but I have certainty
that I'm not on the wrong side of
History here right and and I know this
and in fact
um
I think the lesson of Dark Horse really
is that all of these problems are made
artificially complex
it's not that well both things happen
right uh Simplicity gets complexified
and complexity gets oversimplified and
there's you know you know the things
that are actually binary or imagine to
have like 140 States the things that are
complex you're like no it's black and
white like guys could you could you get
it right could you first assess level of
complexity and could we agree on that
well the question is being made
artificially complex so people become
distrustful of their own ability to
calculate obvious things right and the
point is look if you know how to think
and you know what constitutes evidence
and you look at a puzzle like this and
you say well for example
you know everybody who's got this wrong
seems to think male and female are
somehow human characteristics right they
don't understand how ancient these
properties are and in fact what they're
made of the fact that a flower
displays some of the same
characteristics that animals divided
into these Sexes do yeah tells you
something it means that if you're you
know if your argument starts with you
know people and oppression by some
people of other people you've
misunderstood what this sex thing is to
begin with right well some of them even
think it starts with history or the
written word like the first time that
you know sex shows up in in the written
language is when it starts like okay you
you and your post-modernism are going to
destroy the world stop it already right
it doesn't start with our understanding
or or misunderstanding of a concept if
the concept has an underlying reality it
doesn't matter what we say about it
because the underlying reality does not
change right
what I'm getting at is
the ability to say yeah I look back on
the Gay Liberation movement right and I
am glad that it happened and that
Civilization has
come to understand what it now seems to
understand even though I think that
there's Nuance there that we haven't yet
figured out right what exactly is
homosexuality and where does it come
from that's an important discussion and
I believe we have to have it but the
idea that we can look back on
you know emancipation
um the fight for black civil rights the
fight for gay civil rights we can look
back at these things and we can say yes
it was not clear to people at the time
it is now clear Ada American with
Disabilities Act Right right all these
things and that can be used as a trick
to get you to turn off your mind you
have to be able to say yep I look at
those I see the people who were ignorant
in those situations and worse
um I am not concerned that I am them if
I insist that two plus two equals four
if I insist that pedophilia is bad if I
insist that there is male and there is
female and there are not a multiplicity
of sexes and that yes gender is more
flexible than sex but it does not mean
that this is some vast new UN
misunderstood landscape and you can
adopt different gender Norms but you're
a mammal and therefore you can't change
sex right so I guess it's time for
people to realize that even though they
can't explain the difference between
this and the historical analogs that are
being falsely linked to it there is a
distinction and it is an important one
um and you know
uh you're right men need to stand up uh
on Mass
trans folks need to stand up against
trans activists who are using them as a
shield and you know women need to stand
up for themselves and
when that happens this is this won't
last right this is a tiny number of
people getting a large amount of Power
by pretending to be something that
they're not
so Auckland Pride which as most pride
organizations has been effectively taken
over by the tea part and they're of
course now LGB organizations who are
saying you know what T never belonged
here and they themselves are being
attacked by the T contention Auckland
Pride
uh tweeted in the wake of what happened
in that video that I showed you can show
my screen if you like Zach we also
reject that there was any further
physical threat from our community
towards Parker this is a baseless rumor
that is being perpetrated by those who
feel defeated by the events of today we
urge the media not to repeat these
allegations without evidence
to which the ever awesome JK Rowling uh
responded as a quote tweet there are
multiple videos of Kelly J being
assaulted women have become used to lies
threats of violence and outright denial
of reality but if you imagine anyone
feels defeated think again your men's
rights activist showed the world exactly
who they are let women speak
so I I do hope that this becomes a a
turning point for uh for people and one
more thing to show Zach my screen
also out this week from a a terrific
outfit called the Paradox Institute uh
is a a pamphlet that is downloadable and
printable
um
that is called sex difference research
illuminated myths of gender affirming
care and while this is the PDF that I've
got on my screen I will and it it's got
a scannable QR code and
um has just it's it's concise it's well
done this could be handed out to people
who are beginning to question whether or
not for instance giving puberty blockers
to Children is a good idea uh and it you
know it links again to lots of important
research but is a really good summary of
some of the issues uh in play here so I
recommend that as well yeah it's um
you know even just the term gender
affirming right it's sex denying is what
it is that's right right and you know if
you say it's gender affirming then of
course you know the empathic part of
people wishes to do whatever is
necessary to affirm you know the the
inner being of a person but that's not
what's going on here this is
um a
uh a false flag
of yeah you know using one part of
biology as if it negates another which
is just nonsense that's right and that's
you know that you know
months ago now I wrote a piece on my
substack and I think we talked about we
may I think we have merch actually do
not affirm do not comply right like you
the the Mama Bear Instinct has got to
kick in here yeah uh you know do not do
not affirm your child's decision that
he's a tractor any more than his
decision that he's a princess and do not
comply with uh reprehensible farby
Executives uh overrunning of the federal
government to get you to take
experimental to put experimental shots
into your children right do do not
affirm this thing just because they've
used the word affirm and that sounds
nice and positive I mean it's like the
very language has been used to trick the
more typically agreeable nature of women
into doing this thing that is bad for
their children yeah no and the
the idea of believe your children when
they say stuff when in fact the point is
look actually parenting that ain't
exactly new either right the whole job
of a parent is to affirm that part of
what your kid is doing that should be
affirmed and to steer them in the right
direction for all of the stuff they
shouldn't be doing that's what childhood
is about that's right and the whole idea
that you're supposed to subordinate your
judgment as a parent to what your child
says doesn't make any sense at all that
was a child knows best since went yeah
like when did that show up and you know
we've seen there's plenty of bad
parenting out there uh but you know it's
it's an insane position yeah it really
is
um maybe I'm done ranting for the moment
[Music]